انا ما كنت صغيره كان عندي مشكلتين
المشكله الاولانيه ان انا ما كنتش بعرف
افتح اي باب المشكله التانيه ان انا كنت
دايما بقعد الاقي بالناس في ناس قالت لي
انت لازم تروحي للدكتور عشان تشوفي
المشكله دي ايه
اللي ما كانش لابسه هناك ان انا ما كنتش
بعمل كده علشان في مشكله معينه ان انا كنت
بحب اراقب الناس عشان اكتب عنهم وكنت بقف
قدام اي باب علشان كنت بفكر انا هعرف
افتحه ولا لا طب يا ترى لو فتحته هعرف
ادخل طب
هيبقى وراي بعد كده
الباب كان في بالي مش مجرد حته خشب الباب
بالنسبه لي بوابه اللي انا ادخل على
الحاجه الجديده
كتبت قصه لما كان عندي 8 سنين كان قميت
المكتبه فرحت بها وقالت ان هي هايله جدا
وفيها موهبه
ان في ناقد من اولاد ثقافه هيجي وان انا
لازم يعني اروح اوريها له عشان نبض كويس
قوي هيتعبني
انا رحت فعلا بس وقفت قدامه وهو فضل يقول
اسمي في المايك 10 مرات وانا ما رضيتش
هو كان
بيقول في حد يعيشوا انا في دماغي
يعني حد يقول لي انت تنفعي او تنفعش
ساعتها انا كنت يعني قلقانه جدا ان حد
يقول لي حاجه تخليني
ابطل كتابه
يومها طبعا هو ما عرفنيش ويومها برده انا
قررت ان انا دي اخر مره في حياتي هقف قدام
الباب
12 سنه كده كان في نادي ادبي مشهور جدا في
اسكندريه كان المشهور ان الناس اللي فيه
بتتكسر عظم يعني جدا
فانا روحته حبست جوايا وقلت ان انا هسمع
مش هقلق يعني
فرحت فعلا وما حدش قال والله الناس كلها
كانت نظاره ايجابي جدا
بس كان في ناس معايا
النضج بتاعهم كان وحش جدا الناس دي انا
الناس دي وشها انطفوا وما جتش فين
الغريب في الموضوع ان انا بعد كده بقت في
النادي الادبي ده بقت عضوه فيه بس كنت مش
عاجبني قوي طريقه ان هم دايما كل الناس
عندهم ما بيعرفوش يكتبوا وكل الناس ما
تعرف
ش خدت بالي حاجتين من الناس اللي بتيجي
اللي هي بتيجي مره ما بتحاولش تاني ان
الناس بتصدق
قوي في الفلاني وكاتب الفلاني والحد قال
لك انت هينفع ولا تنفعش وان احنا يعني مش
بنحاول قوي واللي احنا بنجري نرجع الزوم
بتاعتنا المربع الورد
بس ما خلاص هعمل ايه يعني
لحد المهم ده قال لي ان انا ما اعرفش او
ما بينفعش يبقى انا هحاول ازاي
ففضل هاجز عندي يعني كم واحد في مستني
اتكتب وما لقيتش حد
يكتبها وكم شخصيه كان ممكن تضافوا تكون
انت اتقلبها وتديها صوت وحياه وانت ما
عملتش ده
علشان انت كنت
قلقان وخايف
وصدقت ان في حد قالك ما ينفعش او صدقت ان
زي ما قولوا لك كده واحد واحد اتنين وانت
على فكره ممكن واحد واحد يسوي اي حاجه انت
عايزه يسووها انت اللي بتقرر
والحاسد انت مصوره له قصتك او بتقولي له
اي حاجه انت بتعملها هو ميعرفش كل حاجه ما
يعرفكش اصلا هو بيحكم عليك من من خلال
المربع
امكانياتك وراي مش مسلم بيه
فقررت ان انا هعمل حاجه صغيره هعمل كتابه
الورشه بالشال زي النوادي الادبيه اللي
انا كنت بروحها اللي بتخرج الناس في قوالب
وكل نفس الاشاره بعضها وكل الناس بتتكلم
زي بعضها وفي روز وقواعد والمفروض نعمل
كده
كنت عايزه مكان زي اصحابي
كلنا نكتب مع بعض وكلنا نحمل بعض
بعد كده قررت ان انا هروح اعرض الفكره دي
على المكتبه الف
ومرحبوا بها كانت وحشه مجانيه عشان ما حدش
يتحجج يقول غاليه اه دي كانت مش عارفه ايه
روحنا
وكنت رايحه اول يوم مش متخيله مين هيجي او
هعمل ايه انا مش عامله حتى يعني دعايه
اللي هي يعني رحت لقيت حوالي 70 حد حاضر
طبعا عشان تحيه هي ناجحه او لا اكبر في
اسكندريه كان بيجيلها الفرن وهو اغلبهم
بيبقوا عارفين بعض 10 منهم مثلا بيكتب كان
في ناس جديده كلها حماس عايزه تعرف طب
هنعمل ايه
فمستنيين في ناس وقلم وبتبصلي
بقى قواعد قلنا هنعمل ايه كيف تكتب
فقلت لهم القلم واحنا هنفكر مع بعض هنتعلم
من بعض
في ناس يعني قلقت جدا وبصيت لي كده اللي
هو يعني طب احنا جايين نعمل ايه
بدانا نتكلم مع بعض ونتكلم عن اخواتنا
والحاجات اللي احنا بنهرب منها في ناس
كانت جدا ومش عارف تتكلم فضلت قلقانه وعلى
وفي ناس كانت متفاعله وفي ناس كانت طب انا
جايه اتفرج بس انا اكتب ما تتوقعيش يعني
ان انا ممكن
اشدهم
يتفاعلوا معانا قسمتهم جروب وعلى تفوت
مستواهم فالناس بتكتب مع بعض
وبدانا نكتب كلنا مع بعض
وعلى اختلاف الناس قوي كل كتبوا نصوص من
اجمل ما يمكن وفي ناس مكعب ايه موهوبه
واعرفك يومها وفي ناس
عرفت ان هي عندها الاحتماليه عندها
البوتين وبعد كده هي هتبقى كويسه هتقعد
تطير وفي ناس بدات
ان انا كنت عايزه اقوله ان مفيش حد حاجه
اسمها
الفلاني فانا ممكن اقول لك انت
واللي عايزه اقوله برضو ان انت بتخسر
حاجات كتير قوي لما بتقف في مكانك
وما تجربش افضل خبط على الاباء كلها
افضل خبط الناس اللي كانت في جروب عملت
جروب على الفيسبوك ناس كتير جدا ض
ميت له كانوا من بره اسكندريه وكان في ناس
كمان مجرد وبداوا يتفاعلوا معنا ويكتبوا
ويحاولوا علشان في ناس عرفت قد ايه
الكتابه شيء مهم جدا وان انت مش مشكله
خالص ان انت تغير العالم لصالحك او تغير
الناس تبقوا زيك انت بتغير الحياه
الحياه على فكره بالظبط بالظبط زي ما شفت
كتابه
احنا كلنا بنحاول نخبط بعد كده نجري بس ما
حدش بيقف قدامه وبيحاول بكل طريقه ان هو
يفتح
هتقول لي طيب خلاص انا حاولت وعملت اللي
عليا وفضت ادق على كل باب طب وبعدين الباب
ما فتحش هاعمل ايه
هتضطري بس كده
ميرسي جدا